hey guys it's Johanna here today I'm
going to introduce to you one of my
favorite is Asian foods tofu some
consider this as a superfood some don't
even think of this as food and consider
this harmful to the body where do I
stand with this while coming from an
Asian upbringing I've only experienced
and heard about the health benefits of
tofu so my parents friends run a serving
business their daughters consume serving
on a daily basis they have really
beautiful complexion
my grandmother uses tofu as a face mask
to help nourish the skin and to slow
down the aging process so I am
definitely for tofu ladies if you want
smooth and youthful complexion eat tofu
tofu is packed with many nutrients it is
a complete source of protein to vegans
it is high in protein very easy to
digest excellent source of calcium
vitamin B and iron especially for ladies
very low in calories which is great for
weight loss I can go on and on about the
health benefits of tofu but let's get to
know the different types of tofu and for
creative ways you can eat tofu well if
you have tried tofu and you think is
rather blunt and uninteresting don't
worry you're not alone the truth is it
is rather tasteless on its own but
that's the beauty because you can do
anything with it just think of this as a
sponge basically it takes on the flavor
of whatever you cook it with so there
are many different types of tofu let's
get to know the more common ones so you
have silken tofu soft tofu firm tofu and
extra firm tofu let's start with silken
tofu which is what I have in my hand it
has a silky smooth custody texture
it has the highest water content it is
the most delicate of the turbo types
which makes it not suitable for cooking
silken tofu works very well in creamy
and blended foods such as smoothies
desserts puddings salad dressings dips
and can be used as an egg replacement in
baking some of you might also come
across soft tofu so to keep things less
confusing soft tofu is slightly less
smooth has a slightly thicker texture
but can be used in the same way as
silken tofu next firm tofu fan tofu is
most commonly used in cooking it absorbs
flavors really well it can be served
fried pan-fried simmered embraced it
makes a great substitute for ricotta
cheese and eggs in cooking and the
fourth one extra firm tofu it has a very
solid texture it has the lowest water
content holds its shape well and it is
excellent for any kinds of frying
grilling or baking just think of firm
tofu as a meat substitute in fact
Chinese vegetarian restaurants tend to
use extra firm tofu to create thick
meats in the cooking so the more dense a
tofu is the high protein content it will
have and also it will be higher in
calories so I'm going to share with you
four creative ways you can use tofu to
pretty much make anything so let's start
with silken tofu it's perfect to be
added into smoothies if you're on a
dairy-free diet silken tofu is a great
substitute for milk or yogurt in
smoothies the creamy texture will
thicken the smoothie as well for my cup
of smoothie I've blended quite a cup of
Sirkin tofu one cup of frozen fruits
half a cup of water and half a
tablespoon of maple syrup this thick
creamy and satisfying smoothie is only
120 calories have you been dreaming of a
guilt-free dessert
well serving tofu is your answer it can
be used to replace cream
most cream based desserts such as cakes
puddings mousse and even soups it was
seriously slash the calories by more
than half so I've made my chocolate
mousse dessert with only four
ingredients 1 pack of silken or soft
tofu cut a cup of unsweetened cocoa
powder 2 tablespoons of maple syrup and
1 and 1/2 teaspoon of vanilla extract
blend all the ingredients in a food
processor pour into 3d set bowls and
chill in the fridge for one to two hours
or until slightly fun I've topped my
very healthy chocolate mousse dessert
with some strawberries blueberries and
also chopped pistachios this dessert
tastes just as good if not even better
than your traditional chocolate mousse
which calls for a lot of heavy cream
this one serving made with tofu only has
96 calories versus 300 calories using
the traditional recipe now that's saving
more than 200 calories that's a lot of
calories especially if you're watching
your waistline so if you want to indulge
in dessert of course you can just make
them with healthy option up for silken
tofu another calorie buster is sauces
dips or dressings sometimes you might
have a good intention of eating well but
without realizing you're packing on
hidden calories from your salad
dressings or dips here are some examples
of high-calorie dressings it is
absolutely shocking basically the word
creamy means high calories
salad dressing so what I'm going to show
you is how to make a ranch dressing with
only 10 calories per tablespoon not 73
but 10 calories the ingredients you'll
need are 1 cup of silken tofu quarter
teaspoon of garlic powder dried chives
dried parsley and smoked paprika 1
tablespoon of lemon juice and salt and
pepper to taste
puree all the ingredients in a food
processor until you get a smooth and
consistent texture so you're still
getting the creaminess of a dressing
from the silken tofu in fear
stupid all the herbs and spices dip and
lunch away this tastes so good without
the extra calories you got to try it
and finally what can we do with firm or
extra firm tofu easy just think of it as
replacing eggs or meat in recipes so I'm
going to show you a really quick
stir-fry tofu scramble which can be
eaten for breakfast lunch or dinner it
is so simple this recipe calls for three
elements first your tofu which is the
main ingredient any vegetables of your
choice make them colorful and seasoning
this is to add flavors into the dish so
i flatly stir-fried half a block of firm
tofu crumble with garlic spring onion
chili bell pepper carrots and cherry
tomatoes seasoned with turmeric ground
cumin smoked paprika and salt and pepper
it only takes two to five minutes to
cook with tofu depending on how Brown
you want it to be this is such a big
serving for less than 200 calories you
can choose to have it on its own or add
it into tortilla pita wrap top it onto
sandwich or serve it with a side of rice
or noodles the options are endless guys
I've only scratched the surface of what
you can do with tofu I hope this video
has inspired you to gift over try and
add this superfood into your recipes I
would love to see your terrific dish so
make it snap a picture and tag me at
your NASA official and guys if you're
watching my video because you're
passionate about healthy living if you
have considered on becoming a personal
trainer because you would like to help
others to get healthy and to transform
people's lives do check out the National
Academy of Sports Medicine website and
ASM because they are currently offering
a 14-day free trial to their online
personal training costs this course will
provide you with all the necessary tools
and knowledge to help you kick start a
successful fitness career so if you're
interested
Lync and more information is in my
description box don't forget to Like
share this video and subscribe to my
youtube channel for weekly inspiration
all the best